[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode,
number 13 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy
and I'm joined today
by my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Very excited about
this amazing episode.
We're going to be talking
about Firebase finally.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
going to be really good.
Great way to come
back from my vacation.
Talk about a wonderful topic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
Well, for you-- yeah,
you had vacation, yeah.
But before that, we have
a cool thing of the week.
And it's actually related
to one of the things
that we talked about
last episode, which
is about training.
So we have a bunch of
trainings coming on.
And they're going to be
happening very soon actually.
So today's Wednesday, 17th.
So it's actually tomorrow.
Some of them are tomorrow.
MARK MANDEL: Better
get on that quickly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and they're really cool.
So you can go to
cloud.google.com/training,
and you'll find a
bunch of courses.
Some of them are in New
York in the Google office.
Some of them are in Sunnyvale
next to Mountain View.
MARK MANDEL: So these
are actually classes.
You can go to them.
There's a trainer, all
that sort of stuff?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And they are one whole day
of going around Google Cloud
Platform.
So it's actually CB100,
which is the Google Platform
Fundamentals.
MARK MANDEL: Nice, nice.
If you're looking to get started
with Google Cloud Platform,
this could be a really great
way to get up to speed quickly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
know that I've attended
as a student these classes.
And I thought it was amazing.
You get to play with all the
little pieces of the Google
Cloud Platform.
You don't go too
deep into those,
but you just get an idea of
what is the power, what can you
do with it.
MARK MANDEL: If you're
looking to build something,
you kind of go away
and you're like, oh,
now I know a little
bit about everything.
So I can sort of build together
a picture of exactly how I
want to build something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And even cooler
than that-- so not everybody
lives in New York, or especially
not everybody's in Sunnyvale,
so we also have online classes.
And there are
online classes that
are actually happening live.
So you will be able to
ask questions and so on.
So trying to bring the
class experience to people
all around the world.
And they're also happening
February 18th and 19th.
So just go there.
You will have to register, but
it's going to be really cool.
You're going to basically go
through the same concepts.
It's also CB100A, so Google
Cloud Platform Fundamentals.
But from the comfortable couch
in your house if you want to.
MARK MANDEL: You can
sit in your own bed.
You could be in a couch.
You could even do
it in a jacuzzi.
We don't judge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really fancy.
That gives me ideas.
I should try to do
that the next time.
MARK MANDEL: Now don't drop
your laptop into the jacuzzi.
That would be bad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good point.
So as we said, we're
going to be interviewing
two awesome people.
Sara Robinson and--
MARK MANDEL: Vikrum Nijjar.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Vikrum Nijjar.
Both from Firebase.
Sara now working with
us in [INAUDIBLE].
And we're going to be
talking about Firebase.
So let's go with that.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
Today we are joined by
two wonderful guests
that are here today to
talk to us about Firebase.
We've been talking about
it for a little while,
but it's great to have
two people to come talk
to us about it directly.
We have both Sara Robinson
and Vikrum Nijjar.
Thank you very much
for joining us today.
SARA ROBINSON:
Thanks for having us.
VIKRUM NIJJAR:
MARK MANDEL: Now I did manage
to mess up your last names.
I'm very well known
for doing that.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: No,
it was spot on.
MARK MANDEL: Spot on?
Great, great, great.
All right, wonderful.
So before we get
stuck into things,
do you want to give us a bit
of background on yourselves
so people know who you are?
Sara, why don't
we start with you.
SARA ROBINSON: Sure, my
name is Sarah Robinson.
I'm currently a
developer advocate
on the Google Cloud Platform
Team with Mark and Francesc.
And before that I was
a developer advocate
on the Firebase
team with Vikrum.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So Sara
and I have worked together
for a few years now.
I'm Vikrum.
I'm on the SRE Team at Firebase.
So SRE in Google
parlance is sort of
like the DevOps operations
engineering for up time
for Firebase to service.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we've been talking about
Firebase many episodes.
We talked on IoT, on Cloud Spin.
Basically everything [INAUDIBLE]
we say, oh, there's Firebase.
We should talk a little bit
more about that in detail
at some point.
And today's the day.
So why don't you Vikrum, tell me
a little bit what is Firebase?
MARK MANDEL: So Firebase's
mission statement
is to help developers build
extraordinary experiences.
So we, in a nutshell,
provide a service
that lets you spin up
your app, and get started
with the least amount of work.
And we make it easy for
iOS, Android, and web.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
it's mostly for mobile?
SARA ROBINSON: It's
web and mobile.
So we've got three client
libraries, JavaScript client
for the web, and then iOS and
Android clients for mobile.
And then it's also a REST API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
what can you do with it?
SARA ROBINSON: So
essentially there's
three core features that
are part of Firebase.
The first is the
real time database,
which is also my favorite.
So it's the NoSQL JSON database.
And every piece of
data in Firebase
is referenced by a URL.
So it makes it really easy
to write data directly
from the client.
And the really cool thing
is that all the updates
happen in real time.
So any client that's connected
to a Firebase application
will see changes to that
data right as it happens.
They don't have to
refresh the page
or pull to refresh on mobile.
So there's a big
wow factor there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's one of the things
that I really like.
And the cool thing
for me is that you
don't need to do it with
one of the libraries.
You can also use the REST API.
So you can use it with
Go, which is always nice.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: And then the
second product that we have
is static hosting.
So this is
essentially a website,
but it gives you a
rare domain, CDN,
and has a cell at
the push of a button.
So it's really magical in
how easy it is to get set up.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, just
one command, Firebase deploy.
And then your app is live
on it's own Firebaseapp.com
URL, which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very nice.
So you're [? gofmt'd ?]
with HTTPS directly.
SARA ROBINSON:
Yeah, you don't have
to worry about
acquiring the cert.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really cool.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: That
is really cool.
SARA ROBINSON: And
then the third feature
is authentication.
So if you ever
implemented OAuth,
it's not a very fun procedure.
But Firebase luckily takes
care of all that for you.
So we support a number
of different providers
so you can authenticate users
with Facebook, Twitter, GitHub,
Google, or email password
login or authentication,
or anonymous authentication.
And you just need to freeze
in one of the third party
providers.
Just enter your
API key in secret
into your Favorites dashboard.
And then you can start
authenticating users directly
from the client.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
That actually makes writing
applications much easier.
Because I know that when
I'm writing an application,
the worst part is
when you're like,
now I need to add authentication
because I want to be safe.
It's always fun to auth
too dense-- yeah, no, I
don't like it.
SARA ROBINSON:
Yeah, with Firebase
it's just one method--
Call in JavaScript auth
with OAuth pop up.
And then you've got user
authentication in your app.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So
the theme along all
of those three main
offerings that we
have is to try to move people as
fast as possible for their app
without having to
worry about servers.
And then they start
getting wrapped around axle
with getting those set up, and
provision and scaling them.
And we try to end
all of that for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
So for a little bit of
context, how old is Firebase?
How many years--
VIKRUM NIJJAR:
What's its history?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What's the history?
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So
Google acquired
Firebase in October 2014.
And Firebase got its start
during the summer of 2011
while James and Andrew,
the co-founders,
were going through Y Combinator.
And it's a little known fact-- I
guess it is a large known fact.
So the same batch
that we went through,
Meteor also went
through that batch.
Parse also went
through the batch.
And then we were
also in that batch.
So there was three client, back
end of the service offerings
all through YC during
the summer of 2011.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And how did the company evolve?
How did you start?
Why did you start building this?
And why do you have
those three features?
How do you decide
what's what to Firebase?
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So
they were actually
going through YC with a
completely different company.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
It was a company called
Involve, actually,
that was a chat service.
So this is sort of
a business where
you can add chat to your
website without having
to worry about servers.
And the common drumbeat that we
got from our paying customers
at that time was, well,
can we add game data
on top of this chat bus?
Can we add comments?
And so there was
this recurring theme
that people wanted to have real
time features without having
to architect it or build it.
And it was around
that time that we
decided to sort of generalize
that offering into a real time
database.
So we started out with just
the database that summer.
And focused just
on that part of it.
The hosting and authentication
came a couple years later.
But we just focused on
the database at that time.
SARA ROBINSON: And one way that
Firebase grew its user base
really early on was
talking directly
to the developers that were
using it from the start.
So I know even before
I joined, you guys
went to a ton of
hackathons and would
try to get feedback and see
how people were using API
and then iterate on
the product from there.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So we actually
wrote no lines of code
before we started
doing feedback.
So Andrew had mocked
out documentation
for a hypothetical API
and told people, hey,
if you were to
write an application
with this set of APIs,
what would it look like?
So we got a lot of feedback
around the ergonomics
of the API before we even
wrote any code, just to flesh
out is this something that
can be readily consumed.
And so we did hundreds of
hours of video interviews
with developers once the
API did get fleshed down,
once an SDK did exist.
And that was one
of the core tenants
of how we kept the developers'
interest so tightly in focus.
Because if-- you're
sort of in a vacuum.
And you're hacking away,
and you think this is cool.
It doesn't really
matter if it's cool
if it's not solving your
developers' problems.
And we had a very
regimented approach
to doing developer
feedbacks, which
included actually videos
and reviewing the videos,
and not having to worry about
taking notes when we were doing
developer feedbacks.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, I was
always really surprised
when we were almost ready
to launch a new feature,
we would go through a round
of developer feedbacks
and find that there
was a lot of things
that we just didn't even
think about that were revealed
through the feedback sessions.
We were able to improve
before we launched.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
that's interesting,
because I know that
a lot of companies
do that kind of product
management and market studies
and so on for
non-software stuff.
Before you design
something that is hardware,
you let people play with
it and see how they do it.
But I have not heard about that
same technique for APIs, which
is actually a very good idea.
Really like it.
MARK MANDEL: Makes
a lot of sense.
Makes a lot of sense.
Sara, you're talking
about talking directly
with customers.
What are some of the cool
things you saw people
building with
Firebase, or have seen
people building with Firebase?
What sort of cool
examples can we find?
SARA ROBINSON: So one of
my favorites to talk about
is Warby Parker.
They're a glasses company.
They let you order
your glasses online.
And then they send you a couple,
you choose which ones you like.
And then send back the rest.
They have a physical
store in New York.
And that store has
pneumatic tubes.
So when you order your
glasses at the register,
they're shot down to
you via pneumatic tubes.
And the tubes' notifications are
actually powered by Firebase.
MARK MANDEL: I have
Warby Parker glasses.
VIKRUM NIJAR: Those glasses
are powered by Firebase.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL: I knew there
was a reason I loved them.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL: I bought them
in the San Francisco store.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I feel bad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is very, very cool.
What about you?
Do you have one?
VIKRUM NIJAR: Yeah so
my favorite Firebase
app is called Roll20.
So this is a tabletop
gaming app that
Riley the founder has
been with us, essentially
since the beginning.
And I love gaming.
It's a platform built
on Firebase for gaming.
It connects people
with one another
to not only build
games for themselves,
but also play with others.
And it's one of the use cases
where with a very small team,
he was able to
leverage our technology
to build his product.
So yeah, roll20.net.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: I was
looking at that right now.
Looks very cool.
Looks like a very cool game.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL: And there's a case
study on the Firebase site.
Yeah, I've read that before,
and it's really cool.
Stuff like this, especially
in the gaming space,
I especially like
because of the fact
that you've got the real
time updates across web, iOS,
Android, so you have that
cross-platform approach which
is really, really powerful.
I think that the thing that we
as developers and engineers,
we sort of lose sight of how
ubiquitous technologies like
real time, there's a lot
hidden behind the details.
Just because we see it in
Google Docs and Spreadsheets all
the time, or we
see it in Hangouts
doesn't mean it's very
accessible to every developer.
We have huge teams of
people that are building
out Hangouts and Google Docs.
And so by having this
feature set in Firebase,
we give developers the
ability to build those sorts
of features in their products.
SARA ROBINSON:
Makes that real time
accessible to maybe
just a single developer
or a small startup.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that's
actually a very, very, very
interesting point-- the
fact that it looks easy,
but it is not.
So how is it done?
You can you talk a little
bit about the secret sauce?
What's going on in
the Firebase servers?
VIKRUM NIJJAR: Yeah, so
at a very high level,
we fan out this JSON
as Sara mentioned,
to developer SDKs
that are plugged
into their applications.
So at a very high level, that's
sort of what we're doing.
Nuts and bolts of it are whether
it's a browser that's connected
or an iOS device we have, in
the wide majority of cases
a persistent socket that's
connected to our servers.
And then we handle the
fanout of JSON between all
of those connected sockets.
So the core Firebase
server is written in Scala.
We use the awesome Netty
networking pipeline
to handle WebSockets, to handle
REST, like Sarah mentioned.
We have a long
polling implementation
where for browsers that
don't support websockets,
we fall back to.
It's all custom
implemented Scala that's
backed by disk elsewhere.
But for most part, all the magic
happens in our JVM process.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I think that that
may be the first time I hear
about something bringing
Scala at Google.
I don't know that anyone
else that does Scala.
So you have Scala on the JVM,
and you're an SRE for that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's pretty unique.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting,
very interesting.
Well, that's very cool.
So we were talking a
little bit previously
about gaming in Firebase.
I got particularly excited.
I saw there was a recent
Unity, Unity 3D plug-in.
So if people aren't aware, Unity
is an engine for doing games
in both 3D and 2D.
So there's a Unity
plugin for Firebase
to do real time event
[INAUDIBLE] integration stuff.
Can you tell us more about that?
That's pretty exciting.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: Yeah, so
it's an early preview.
So you can find access to
it in our Google group.
So if you go to the Firebase
Google Group, the public one,
and search for
Unity, you'll see one
of our engineers
made a call out to be
able to take a look at
one of the early examples.
We've had a steady drumbeat
of requests for Unity,
essentially since the beginning.
MARK MANDEL: I'm not surprised.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: And like
Sara mentioned earlier,
our first SDK was JavaScript.
The second and third ones
were iOS and Android.
And Unity for the
most part runs on C#.
And the way that the
architecture there is we
didn't have a simple plugin
that we could have added
without a lot of heavy lifting.
And so even though it
remained a priority,
we didn't have the bandwidth
to execute on that early on.
And it was once we joined Google
that we had the engineering
resources to be able to build
something to allow people
to use Firebase on Unity.
MARK MANDEL: It's
still early days?
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So I
don't have any examples
off the top of my
head of people that
have built games on it yet.
MARK MANDEL: That
was my next question.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: But soon.
Unity is huge across
all platforms.
And giving both indie developers
and big shops the ability
to add those sorts of
features to their games,
we realize is
extremely important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Now that
you mention indie developers,
there's something
that I really like
about Firebase, which is it's
actually free for many cases.
What is the pricing?
I know that the free
tier is very nice.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, it's
essentially free forever,
up to 100 concurrent
connections.
So that means 100
simultaneous people
on your website or mobile
app at the same time, which
is actually a lot.
So it's a good
problem to have if you
have 100 people on your
app at the same time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's very nice.
That basically takes
you already to the point
where, well, maybe I should
start making money off this?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
VIKRUM NIJJAR: Yeah, if you
have 100 concurrent people,
and you're not making money--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
don't think my webpage
has [INAUDIBLE]
gotten 100 in a day.
SARA ROBINSON: And
then on the free tier,
you also get access
to Firebase hosting.
So you can deploy it to your
own Firebase app.com domain.
And then the self-service pay
plan start at $49 a month.
And then the concurrent
limits go up from there.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: There is also a
Spark plan, which is $5 a month
to give you the custom domain.
We've heard a lot of feedback
where $49 was too high
for the new developers.
Whereas the free
gives you some things,
the $5 plan gives you
your own white labeling,
and some of the features
of the heartland.
So we heard that feedback
from the indie devs,
so we have a $5 plan as well.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned that
some time ago you
were together with
Parse in the same batch
for a YC, Y Combinator.
.
Later on, you got
acquired by Google.
Parse got acquired by Facebook.
We all know Parse
ended up being shut
down-- well, at some point.
And the migration
was great, but still,
some developers felt like
oh yeah, this was a problem.
What can you say to those that
might be a little bit concerned
about this happening
to Firebase?
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So in
general, it was very sad,
the shutdown of Parse.
And we know that team.
It's just bad for the
ecosystem at large, let alone
for the developers and the
Parse team, which we know.
And there are many
apps that were
built on Parse and Firebase,
and Firebase and Meteor.
And so they're not
completely siloed.
I think that the
thing to keep in mind
is what these sorts
of offerings provide,
whether it's Firebase
or Parse, is leverage
for developers to
build their products
and build their visions.
And as long as there
is a need for that,
I think this ecosystem will
continue to exist and flourish.
Whether the particular
circumstances around Parse
can be dissected, I think
it's pretty unambiguous
that Google supports cloud
in general and developers,
in particular.
SARA ROBINSON:
Yeah, I know there
is lots of exciting
Firebase features
that the team is working on.
And Google's definitely
100% behind Firebase.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: So stay tuned.
We have a lot to
announce at Google I/O.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
I have to ask.
You might tell me
no, but is there
anything you can maybe
hint at, or any new
features that we could
possibly get a little scoop on?
Just here?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The only
stuff I know is confidential.
[LAUGHTER]
What about you?
VIKRUM NIJJAR: The same.
I just say that I think it
will just reaffirm Google's
commitment to Firebase.
Once you see what gets
announced and released at I/O,
I think there will
be no doubt as
to the commitment and longevity,
which is sort of envisioned
for Firebase.
SARA ROBINSON: Stay tuned.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: I know that at
least in our team, Developer
[INAUDIBLE] for
Cloud, we are not
forced to talk about Firebase.
It's something that is there,
but we choose to use it,
just because it's awesome.
I don't think that's going to
be going away anytime soon.
MARK MANDEL: We've covered,
it seems like a lot
of things about Firebase.
Is there anything
that you wanted
to mention about Firebase that
hasn't been mentioned already?
Or anything that's
particularly amazing about it
that you want to
kind of highlight?
SARA ROBINSON: Actually the
integration between Firebase
and Cloud-- recently there
was and Android Studio
update release that makes
it really easy to integrate
Firebase into your Android app.
You can just do it directly
through the Android Studio
interface.
And we've got a tutorial
on how to do that.
And you can actually add
an App Engine back end
to your Firebase app.
So we'll put that
in the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
about you, Vikrum?
VIKRUM NIJJAR: One of
the questions I always
get, whether it's related
with Parse or Firebase,
and how much we
love using it is--
so I have a lot of
friends and family
who I've evangelized
Firebase to.
And so I'm on the SRE team.
And when things
aren't working, I'll
get personal calls
to my personal phone,
saying what's wrong
with the service?
Get it back up.
I just wanted to let people
know that service availability
and up time, and the areas
around a magical cloud
service being up, are first
and foremost on our team's
priorities.
And I hear from
those-- my brother
and my close friends who
are also using Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really
like the Firebase SRE,
but it's not only about
OKRs and keeping it safe.
It's like otherwise your
family will shout at you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL:
Otherwise, your mom's
not going to talk
to you for a week.
VIKRUM NIJAR: Yeah,
her app was down.
MARK MANDEL: Well, thank you
very much Sara and Vikrum,
for joining us.
We really appreciate
you taking the time
to talk to us about
Firebase today.
SARA ROBINSON:
Thanks for having us.
VIKRUM NIJAR: It's
been a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
VIKRUM NIJJAR: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So thank you very
much again to Sara and Vikrum
for being here with us today.
I really loved the conversation.
I learned a lot about
Firebase and also the way
they do things.
Very interesting the way they
do their project management.
I really like that.
So we actually
asked the question,
which was the delicate
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Delicate
I like that.
I like that a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which was
about so Parse was shut down.
What about Firebase?
What are the plans and so on?
And we actually found, right
after finishing the interview
with them that
James Tamplin, one
of the co-founders of
Firebase, wrote a blog post
on the Firebase blog about
the shutdown of Parse
and the future plans
of Firebase at Google.
So if you're interested in that,
I think it's a very great read.
It gives a bunch of
links to other things,
what they're working on.
They actually also
mentioned the Unity plug-in
that you were so
interested about.
So I think it's a great read if
you want to know more about it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely.
And if you're interested
to see sort of a snapshot
glance of what they've been
up to with Firebase and what
sort of ideas they've got
coming up in the future,
it's a good read.
Definitely have a look-- in
the show notes, obviously.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, and before we
finish with this
amazing episode,
I think we should go for
the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL:
Question of the week.
OK, great.
So were talking about
this before actually,
amongst ourselves.
We were talking
about-- so obviously,
you've got the cloud console.
If you have a
laptop, you sit down,
you can have a
look at everything
that's going on inside your
Google Cloud Platform Project.
But what do you do if,
say, you're traveling,
or just generally
more mobile, you
don't have access to a laptop?
What do you do in that instance?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
there's a couple options.
The first one is trying
to access the console
with your browser
on a mobile phone.
And you will see
that it actually
not a great, great option.
MARK MANDEL: Doesn't
work so good?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's not
incredibly responsive.
Let's go with that.
But that's actually
not a big problem
because there's a much
better option which
is we have native apps
for both iOS and Android,
which actually, they're
just called Google Cloud
Console on both the Play
Store and the App Store.
MARK MANDEL: We'll
have links to both
of those in the show notes.
But now we were both
playing with them
and having a look at them.
And they're really nice.
So you have an incident,
like something goes down.
You're using Cloud Monitoring,
which should be, obviously.
You want to see what's going on.
You've got direct access to
that incident, see what it is.
You've got access to your logs.
You can see charts and reports,
and what your resources
are doing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Even if
everything is going on normally
and everything is
perfect, I personally
like to go and see the graphs,
like oh yeah, everything is up.
You can see if your machine
crashed for any reason.
You have access to all the logs.
So it's very nice to have.
And then there is this
thing that we were
watching this a minute ago.
And it just blew my mind.
MARK MANDEL: It's really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
was on my Android app.
I'm assuming the iOS
app also does it,
but I'm not really sure.
But on the Android app, I
went to one of my machines.
And then I clicked on
the little burger menu,
and I saw one of the options
was SSH into this machine, which
is pretty freaking amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Suddenly
we had an SSH terminal
on our mobile phone connecting
to our compute engine instance.
And we're like, oh, now
we can just SSH around.
That's pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So next
step, you needed a keyboard?
Or maybe you're just
really good at typing?
But yeah, really,
really amazing.
I'm very excited about
this and actually going
to be using it much
more now that I
know I can SSH into
my cloud instances
from anywhere in the world.
MARK MANDEL: Now
I really love it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very, very cool.
So yeah, we'll have a bunch
of links to both apps,
and I'm actually going to be
tweeting about this because I
have the snapshot.
And it's just amazing.
Yeah, very excited.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I've been
away for a little while.
Francesc, why
don't you update me
on where you're going to be
in the next upcoming weeks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm actually going
to be in a bunch of places.
On Friday, I'm flying to Dubai.
I'm going to Dubai
for GopherCon.
MARK MANDEL: See ya!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
there's GopherCon Dubai.
So it's the newest Go
conference in the world.
Right now there
is GopherCon India
that is happening right now.
GopherCon Dubai is right after.
And I'll be there for two days.
After that, what else?
I actually am planning
not on traveling too much,
Other than in March will
be South by Southwest.
And then back to San
Francisco for GCP Next.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very nice.
I think my travel stuff is
still pretty much the same.
I'll be at the Launch Hackathon
on the 26th of February.
From there, everything is
pretty much in California.
It's nice.
I'll be at Game
Developer Conference.
I'll be helping
out at the booth.
I'll definitely be there.
So if you're there,
please come say hello.
I will be at GCP Next as well,
which I'm super excited about.
And I'll also be at
Strada, as well as
doing some fun stuff there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very, very cool.
So I think that before we
leave, I think it's always
a good thing to do, which is
going through all the ways
people can contact us.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, because
we love questions.
We love comments.
We love everything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I'm going to be
the one asking the questions.
So Twitter?
MARK MANDEL: @GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Google+?
MARK MANDEL: +GCPpodcast
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
have a sub Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: /R/GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then our email?
MARK MANDEL:
Hello@GCPpodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And our webpage?
MARK MANDEL: GCPpodcast.com.
Very easy to remember.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
MARK MANDEL: There you go,
so please send us stuff.
We love to hear from you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
nothing better than coming up
to the office on Monday
morning and seeing some emails
from people saying, hey,
your podcast is awesome,
and I have questions.
So saying is like, hey, your
podcast is not that good.
These are our ideas
of how to improve it.
We're open to both.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
most definitely.
Constructive criticism
is always welcome,
but we love the interaction.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Well, so thank you
so much for coming
back from Australia
and being here again
with me today, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
very much for joining me
as well, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]